hey guys come here with a beautifully
crafted story-driven gain spot news
update one second mr. Sten huh
apparently plot is highly overrated hmm
that's according to League of Legends
designer Tom Abernathy who says
developers should instead focused on
developing strong characters plot is
highly over rated he said during a game
developers conference presentation at
the Moscone Center in San Francisco this
week abernathy who previously worked at
Microsoft on Halo Reach said internal
and external research proves that out
it's not plot that truly hooks gamers
rather characters users don't remember
plot what they do remember is they
remember characters players become
hooked in a game if they care about its
characters focus on the things that they
will retain that are going to be the
most important to them in the long run
focus on character he said also drew the
top co-presenter riksha gross the third
a design lead at microsoft said most
players do not finish games he estimated
that only about a third of players
actually finish the games they play so
do you agree with these comments let us
know in the box below and for all the
other news out of GDC just head on over
to gamespot com and click the little GDC
tab at the top of the page